لان دعم اجراءات قيس سعيد في البدايه
الطيف من الاحزاب والمنظمات الا ان ما
يمكن اعتباره جناح الموالاه حصلت بعد مع
الوقت حتى طالت انتقادته قيس سعيد
وتوجهاته من ابرز القوه التي دعمت سعيد
حزب الشعب وحزب البعثه الاشتراكي هو حركه
تونس الى الامام لكنها انتقدته خصوصا بعد
اصداره قانون انتخابيا خاصا بالانتخابات
التشريعيه اما في المعارضه فبرزت اعتلافات
جمعت احزاب وشخصيات بينها جبهه الخلاص
الوطني برئاسه احمد نجيب الشابي وتاسست في
مايو 2022 تضم والدتك كانت سياسيه واعتبرت
اجراءات سعيد انقلاب على الشرعيه من ابرز
مكوناتها حركه النهضه التي تصدرت في
البرلمان السابق قبل حله بن سعيد اضافه
الى حزب قلب تونس وائتلاف الكرامه كانت
تضم حركه مواطنون ضد الانقلاب واحزاب
الاخرى والشخصيات المستقله ودعت سعيد
للتناحي والى انتخابات المبكره تشرف عليها
شخصيه قضائيه توافقيات كتله معارضه اخرى
وهي كتله الاحزاب الاجتماعيه الديمقراطيه
وشكلت خمسه منها اقتلافا هي التيار
الديمقراطي والحزب الجمهوري وحزب التكتل
وحزب العمال والقطب الديمقراطي تتحركوا
بموازاه حرك جبهه الخلاص وتختلف معها
لكنهما تلتقيان في مناهضه توجهات واجراءات
سعيد كما دعت لمقاطعه جماعيه للانتخابات
التشريعيه ووضع خريطه طريق لانقاذ تونس
الحزب الدستوري الحر وقت راسه عبير مرسي
وهو محسوب على نظام بن علي ويعرض الجميع
بما فيهم قيس سعيد حذرت رئيسته من
الاعتراف باي مؤسسه تنبثق عن ما سمته
المسار غير الشرعيه وما سر الديكتاتوريه
بعيدا عن الاحزاب السياسيه يعد اتحاد
الشغل من اهم القوى المجتمعيه الاتحاد
ايضا اجراءات الصعيد وسماها مسارا تصحيحيا
لكنه لاحقا رفض المشاركه في الحوار
السياسيه الذي دعى واعتبر الانتخابات
التشريعيه بلا رائحته ولا لون
مع بعض المنظمات والهيئات الاجتماعيه
لاعداد مبادره انقاذ ضمن خيار ثالث واعلن
قيدي فيه رفض اي حوار مع من يعتبرون حركه
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو قلابا واصفا
اياهم بالمسؤولين عما سماه عشريه الخراب
يفترق المعارضون لقيس سعيد بينما يدعو امن
عام اتحاد الشغل لما سماه معركه وطنيه
بهدف انقاذ تونس مضيفا ان هناك مجتمع
المدنيا ومنظمه وطنيه تقول للحاكم لا
للعبه بالبلاد